[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about all the coolest
developer news
from Google in the last week.
Now before I get
started, take a moment
to subscribe so you don't
miss a single episode.
Daydream Labs has put
out another blog post
on what they've learned
from rapidly prototyping
virtual reality concepts.
This week, they discuss
social interaction.
It turns out being in
VR with others amplifies
and improves the experience, as
long as you take a few things
into account.
Click through to the blog
post for their guidelines.
Did you discover and catch the
Firebass time-traveling digital
fish at Google I/O?
If so, you'll want to check out
this behind-the-scenes article
on how we created the alternate
reality game that teaches you
about Firebase.
If not, follow the link
anyway and check out the game.
It was a lot of fun.
Notifications are
a key interaction
between your Android
app and your users,
and Android N provides a better
notification user experience
with updates that include
a visual refresh, improved
support for custom views,
and expanded functionality
through direct reply,
a new messaging style,
and bundled notifications.
Check out the post for
more details and code.
Does your Android
app derive keys
using the SHA-1 PRNG algorithm
from the crypto provider?
If so, you'll need to start
using a real key derivation
function and possibly re-encrypt
your data in Android N.
The post has more.
Google Stackdriver provides
monitoring, logging,
and diagnostics for
applications on Google Cloud
Platform and AWS.
Learn more in these
recent blog posts
on adding ad hoc logs
to your application
while it's still running using
log points and six things
Stackdriver brings
to the DevOps table.
Creating a few Google Forms
manually is manageable,
but what if you needed to
create hundreds or thousands?
Check out this post on
how Google Apps Script can
help you scale by generating
Google Forms programmatically.
The Google Maps operations team
just built a brand new Google
Maps APIs course.
It was developed in
collaboration with Udacity
and teaches you best practices
when using our web APIs.
Whether you're new to
the Google Maps APIs
or just want a
refresher, this course
will teach you how to start
adding location features
and map visualizations
into your websites today.
In the last episode of
"The Mobile Ads Garage,"
the team showed you how to
implement AdMob interstitials
on iOS and Android.
In this new episode,
they're back
to show you how to
put interstitials
to work in the best ways
possible with some best
practices.
Don't
Forget to subscribe so you don't
miss a single episode of what's
new and awesome.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]